Just another person that seems to be a key figure in this,
in the mythology of this is Bob Lasar. It'd be interesting.
Maybe there's others you can tell me about, but, um, uh, Bob,
who's also been on Joe Rogan,
but his story has been told quite a bit and he's got the, I,
I think he said that he witnessed some
of the work being done, uh,
on the spacecraft that was in, you know,
that was captured. And so on in order to, uh,
try to reverse engineer some of the technology in terms of the propulsion.
And so what are your thoughts about his story,
how it fits into the mythology of this whole thing and a broader you
follow just you follow just community.
Okay.
So regarding Bob was R with respect to his claims.
Um, again,
I have no way to adjudicate whether or not he actually,
you know, encountered this. I do have friends who are,
and the people that I know who
know his story, some know him, um, believe him.
And they have said to me that the most important thing that
they think he has said, in fact, one of them, I think, made a,
made a meme out of it or something like that was basically, he said,
uh, maybe the public, you know, I regret making it public.
Maybe the public isn't ready for this kind of information.
And basically they've, they emphasize that to me.
And they emphasized it so much that they wanted me to know. Right.
So that is somewhat creepy to me. So I think, okay,
this port guy, Bob was, are so many people, you know,
this is what happens to people who have experiences like this they're
questioned, their reputations are put on the line.
In some instances they're,
their reputations are manipulated on purpose to make them look on credible.
To me as I'm a scientist,
it's just inspiring that it kind of gives this kind of,
I'm not even thinking of,
is there an actual spacecraft being hidden somewhere and studied and so on.
I'm thinking of it. Like, I dunno,
it's a thing that gives you a spark of a dream, you know, to,
as a reminder,
that we don't understand most of how this world works.
And then we can build technologies that aren't here today that will
allow us to understand much more. And then it's kind of like,
almost like a feeling that it provides, uh, it inspires and makes you dream.
That's that's the way I see the Bible as our story. I necessarily.
People ask me, cause I'm at MIT,
people ask me like the Bibles are actually good at MIT and so on. I don't know.
And I personally don't care. Like it's a, that's not,
what's interesting to me about that story. To me,
the myth is more interesting. Not interesting actually,
but inspiring because inspiring you're suggesting that the myth
inspires you to create reality. Yes. Yeah. I think that's, that's true.
So even if it's like, not real,
in some sense, just like you said, it does in some sense it, uh,
it doesn't.